[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
image compression with the fast Fourier
transform and now we're gonna talk about
how to do image compression using the
wavelet transform in Python okay so this
is my Python example of image
compression using the the discrete
wavelet transform and this is almost
identical in spirit this is exactly the
same as image compression using the fast
Fourier transform except instead of
doing an FFT of our image we're going to
do this discrete wavelet transform and
that should be better at capturing kind
of multiple scales in these images so
big scales that are the size of the
image all the way to really really fine
scales like hair and fur and grass and
things like those ok so morally this is
the same story except we're gonna use
the discrete wavelet transform for for
representing the image ok so the first
thing we're gonna do is just compute the
wavelet transform of our image and look
at you know what what that does ok so
here we're going to load this image of
my dog Mort ok that's simple and here in
this code what we're doing is we're
going to compute a two-dimensional
wavelet decomposition so just like in
the FFT we had to do the FFT to for a
matrix for an image that's an array here
if you want to do the wavelet
decomposition of a two-dimensional array
rather than a one dimensional signal
like an audio signal if you want a
Fourier transform an image you run this
wave deck to this wavelet decomposition
- this is in the PI wavelets package so
you're going to have to install that
this PI WT it's PI wavelets and then you
can run this so it's one line of Python
to run this two-dimensional wavelet
transform and we are doing a two-level
wavelet so we'll have to kind of layers
of this this wavelet decomposition and
we're gonna use the demo xi1 wavelet
family this is the mother wavelet and
you could try other things here you
could do a horror wavelet a koi flood
you know in fact I encourage you try
other wavelets families and see what
changes in this in this framework ok
so we've we've computed the wavelet
decomposition and now all we're doing is
basically reorganizing the information
in this coefficient matrix to show you
kind of what the wavelet is doing in
spirit to this image that's what I'm
gonna show you down here now it's a
little hard to see depending on on your
screen so I really hope you can see this
what we have in the upper left corner is
kind of the low res coarse-grained
version of Mort I always think if this
is kind of like the baseline low res
image and then what we're going to do is
we're going to add iteratively
refinements to that image at this level
and at this level okay so this is kind
of an inexpensive approximation a
compressed version and then we're gonna
add these these subtle refinements at
higher and higher frequencies kind of at
these higher these higher wavelet levels
of our of our multi-resolution
decomposition and you can see that these
have a lot of information where there's
a lot of detail okay so for example
there's information kind of you know at
the ears and it where as collar is that
has whiskers on its tail and not that
much information you know in the snow or
in these regions that where all of the
color is basically constant okay now
this is kind of interesting in the olden
days when you used to load images on a
slow modem like this is before the year
2000 before JPEG 2000 and wavelets you
oftentimes if you loaded a bitmap it
would actually raster scan that bitmap
as it was loading on your screen so
super slow really you know frustrating
to watch this slow load of images
nowadays fast forward into the kind of
the modern era with the wavelet
decomposition now if you load a really
really big high-res image on a slow
internet connection what will happen is
you'll get very quickly the full image
but at a very coarse blocky resolution
so you might actually be able to see
these big kind of fat pixels in this
coarse grain blurry version of the image
and then as more information comes
across the slow internet connection you
start to load the next level of the
wavelet decomposition you can see those
blocky
blurry image start to come into focus
you can see additional features come in
you can start to see okay now I see
details around the ears and the tail on
the snout and then as that last level of
wavelet decomposition loads you can see
it come into even better focus and it
kind of gets more and more crisp as the
data streams in and so that's really
nice that's especially important for
things like you know streaming
television Netflix images where if you
have low bandwidth for a little while
you don't want to get no image you just
want the image to kind of adaptively
degrade or refine based on how much
bandwidth you have okay so that's what
this wavelet decomposition allows you to
do which is super cool okay so if you
only have a little bit of bandwidth it
focuses it in the stuff you know the big
coarse-grained stuff that matters if you
have a little bit more bandwidth you get
medium scale features and if you have
all the bandwidth you know you you can
get all the texture and the fur and
everything okay so that's really cool
and I should point out I'm telling you
kind of a very shallow treatment of the
wavelet decomposition here this is a
deep subject melot's book is about that
thick on the wavelet transform so check
out the documentation you know read some
of these these core foundational
textbooks if you want to know more about
this and actually use this I mean this
is still a subject of active research
there you know this happened within many
of our lifetimes this transformation
from kind of JPEG Fourier compression to
wavelet jpeg2000 compression really
really interesting stuff okay and then
I'll show you how to use this for
compression so notice that a lot of this
is kind of just gray no texture nothing
going on this means that there's a lot
of room to compress to throw away small
wavelet coefficients and still get a
good faithful representation a Mort okay
so that's what we're doing here just
like we've always done this is just like
the Fourier transform compression
example except now instead of an FFT to
we're gonna do a wavelet decomposition
to okay so just the same one line we're
gonna use the dobashi
wavelet family and here we're gonna do a
four layer decomposition in my previous
example I did a two layer decomposition
so I could plot it for you when you
start to get into higher and higher
level d compositions it's really hard to
visualize on a computer screen but it's
great for compression okay so we're
gonna use a four level decomposition and
what we're going to do just like before
we're going to order our wavelet
coefficients from biggest to smallest
and we're basically going to just define
these thresholds to chop off and only
keep the first 10% the first 5% the
first one percent and the first point
five percent largest wavelet
coefficients and then we're going to see
how accurate those reconstructions are
compared to the original image okay just
like we did in the Fourier example so if
you run all this code you find this is
if you keep if you multiply this by a
hundred you get the percentage this is
keeping the first 10% of the wavelet
coefficients and you see this is a
almost perfect representation of more
you could probably even read my phone
number on his collar and maybe that's a
challenge image challenge this is with
5% of the wavelet coefficients one
percent of the wavelet coefficients and
0.5% so you can see that there's a
little image degradation in fact this is
what I was telling you before like when
you have an image load on a low
bandwidth internet connection it kind of
looks like this you can actually see the
little grainy bits you know holding that
picture together and then as more
information streams across the network
you start to refine and see kind of
better resolution features you know and
eventually you get all of the details
and the hair and everything ok so what
you really need to do is you need to
actually do a head-to-head comparison of
this wavelet compression with the FFT 2
version of the compression I mean it's
exactly the same pipeline with wavelets
and with fast Fourier transform and then
you should compare kind of side by side
what does it look like if I keep 5% of
the largest wavelet coefficients versus
5% of the largest for
coefficients which image has better
quality and keeps more of the original
features of the image okay so that
that's something you should do as
homework is kind of code these up next
to each other and actually look at them
you could even compute the norm of the
error between the original image and the
reconstructed image so you could
quantify how different these images are
in kind of a metric space so you could
just literally compute the norm of the
difference of those two arrays using the
wavelet compression and using the
Fourier compression that would be pretty
interesting
okay so that is just very high-level
shallow overview of image compression
with wavelets this is the basis of JPEG
2000 image compression so I mean this is
not a small field this is a huge field
this has changed how we collect and
store and send images and movies and
audio super important in the satellite
era in the digital communication era
this is just you know the very briefest
overview of how to do this in Python
alright thank you